*Swedish Noises* The rule is simple -
You laugh,
You D̠̘͞ͅI͈̻͕̲ͅE̦̙͕̩̼.
Let's go, bros.
???? thumbs up???
"Bat Man But I Removed SOME Animations"
Oh my god.
I love these
*Pewds snickers*
Okay, pretty normal so far.
"Hey what are you-"
(gunshot)
TAHAHAHAH
NOOOO!!
(laughs ... more)
alright lets see the batman
Come on.
"Get it open."
"On it."
"Bring the whole God damn place down."
*Pewds laughs*
"Stay focused!"
"We'll be out of here before anyone can stop us."
*Silence*
Who would have thought...
...that all they needed to do...
...to fix the Tell Tale Games...
...is this remove all the animations?
And it's ta-weny times better!
"Sometimes, you need a monster."
c-come in! come on!
OH MY GOD IT'S BATMAN!
*look at him enjoying himself*
Get  'em Bat Man!
wOw the action is InCrEdIbLe!
Woah!
Where'd they learn-
What is this new Jujutsu?
*giggle*
WoW
"Without a scratch"
"So far"
*dun dun dUN DUN*
"You broke the law"
He's asserting his dominance!
*insert epic fight noises*
(his laugh uwu)
Why is it so funny?
It's so dumb.
Alright I think that's enough,
10 out of 10.
*meme review?*
Well, I guess I failed already, first clip guess I'll die
I'm fine. *doubt*
Turns out I have an extra life.
Oh my God it NiNjA
*I don't know if Ninja is speaking or just laughing?*
[Ninja] swipe up
[Pewd's from stream] There's briDGES IN FORTNITE?
[Ninja] There are two bridges.
[Pewd's] WHAT THE **** HAVE I DONE?
[Ninja] Look dude, I'll make sure to steer us away from those, okay? *a true bro*
(weird throat noise turns into laugh?)
I played Fortnite for 3 hours
and it was totally fine I'm so proud of myself.
Who says I haven't become a better person?
Who says I can't learn from my mistakes?
Thank you Ninja *with a Swedish J* very cool
ya know, lot of things when you play games
are you satified *fruit* or the
things that frustrate you about games? what do you wanna see games do?
eyubagidkhsg
elon: "uuhh, I don't know if I should say"
come on elo-huh huh huh huh ha
you workin on a game too?
he's with dog?? idk help me out
like idunknow, ah- oh- i- i- i- du- du- bua bua bua
more R rated? *cheeky wow* idk
*pewds laughed he's now officialy dead* also pause at 3:09 tell me he doesnt look like elon reacting to the deer
tryna be honest here
todd is like WE'RE ON IT, WE'RE WORKING ON IT
*egg on frying pan sounds*
DOPE
thats awesome ta ha ha
This clip aged well a preview of when doc goes back to games
*music*
y- AAAAHHHHHHH
.... oh i get it tyAHAHAHAH
*neck has been deleted*
he head through the bathroom, I get it he got banned again
docs only weakness
I got my br-jeheheheheheheheh
docs got his bathrooms B)
*ear rape* you see the full context here is that he went into the bathroom
he filmed inside a public bathroom
I used to be such a big doctor disrespect faN
HoW coULD DOcToR DiSReSPeCT Do ThIS
doesNt HE KnOw TherES PeNisS FlYIng EvERYwhERE In A BaThRoOM?!
Has anyone ever been in a goddamn bathroom?
Like a mens bathroom? I know like half of you haven't. (yeah cause all of his subscribers are bots ;))
it's not like tha- *wheezes*
maybe I dont get it. I clearly don't get it.
But you won't see penis unless you go HMMMmMmMmMmm???
Like just filming in a bathroom when people clearly know theres a camera.
I don't really see a problem with that alright?
If you go into a bathroom with a hidden camera
n-now thats fricked up okay? (bet pewds has done that)
it couLDvE BeEN sO BaD *cries*
Involuntary moan
Hey there I'm James McAvoy.
and youre only one week away from seeing sherlock gnomes in the theaters
you can get your tickets in the link below *insert pewds laughing*
Hey there I'm J-
Sherlock gnomes
I can't wait to see sherlock gnomes
he looks completely faded (like spiderman)
n-word is held hostage (i need the pass)
okay he plays it again
He's gnomes yo
they're touchering him
*pewds laughing*
James McAvoy
what else has he acted in-What???
is that the same guy? hes been in so many good films.
split wasnt that great
why is he not credited wait there he is SHERLOCK gnomes
gnomeo and juliet
this man signed a contract 7 years ago
see this is the thing they do with actors. If they wanna see a sequal
I think they are contracted to it (wait what about dora)
most likely he was. So, here he is.
WHAT?I IM ONLY One WEEK AWAY To wAtcInG SheRloCk GnoMES? WhaT?!
Oh, God.
Sorry i feel for him. I will truely do.
Video: you see my sword isnt actually my weapon of choice.
Urgh, God Damnit